duda da silva como decíamos sería el
favorito para las elecciones
presidenciales esto según algunos
sondeos de opinión a qué atribuye usted
este posicionamiento de lula
bueno si es el favorito primero por
cuenta de la propia incompetencia del
gobierno actual presidencial bolsonaro
no logró desarrollar el país no logró
poner calmo el tema económico ninguno de
su promesa logró efecto entonces lo que
llevamos de regreso al pasado el índico
se está pasando ahora con el nombre de
lula y la falta de otro líder que tenga
tanto carisma y tanta competencia en
unir fuerzas políticas a veces muy
diferentes ahora en una reciente
entrevista que le ofreció a la revista
'time' condenó la invasión rusa eugenia
pero no obstante afirmó que el
presidente ucrania hablamos por supuesto
de volodymyr schilansky también es
culpable de la guerra que impactó cree
usted que podría tener la guerra en la
política y en todo este proceso
electoral de brasil quizás la guerra
podría darle más fuerza o por el
contrario empañar la imagen de lula
ningún ningún efecto tiene en brasil
no importa la brasileño la etapa son
además de su frontera somos un país de
27 estados cada estado es casi como un
país de la américa hispánica es como
somos tan dependientes en relación al
efecto del mundo en términos de
construcción el pensamiento político del
brasileño que incluso no nos vemos como
latinos a pesar de ser más latinos así
que no de verdad el tema internacional
es selenski de putting no no tiene
impacto ninguno cualquier que sea la
las manifestaciones dentro de
lula cuanto al evolucionar presupuesto
largo también apoyó a putin en su
momento en cuando tú tienes versa la
invasión entonces en este sentido los
dos contrincantes en brasil tienen la
misma posición y relajación
a la guerra ay ay culpa de los tres
grados hay relaciones que tienen que ver
con otros países que están muy lejos y
que no tiene interferencia directa
hembras y cayos saltemos ahora al otro
lado del arco político como se encuentra
posicionado el presidente de jair
bolsonaro en caso de que las elecciones
fueran hoy
persona no tiene un rechazo muy grande
como estamos hablando de casi la mitad
de la población que les rechaza
o sea por rechazar su gobierno o sea por
rechazar el en cuanto candidato en
cuanto próximo presidente
de verdad que no tiene mucha chance de
elegir se deje elegir se que no sea
algún hecho muy grave que es que pase en
las elecciones algo como un equívoco de
lula o quizás otro de estos escándalos
de intentona de matarle pero muy
posiblemente no va a degradar nuevamente
pero ahora si no surge una tercera vía
no tiene mucha chance de derecho de
ganar las elecciones